you took a lie detector test and and
passed the lie detector test saying that
you do not regret your whatever it was a
tweet or a story or something about Kobe
you got to be true to your [ __ ]
stand-up man I mean dude I see all these
people whenever some celebrity guys I'm
like [ __ ] wrenching their [ __ ]
clothes publicly making it by themselves
and it's always nauseating to me it's
like it's like that we mow that thing
with people used to do on Facebook where
it's like
you know my dad's gone 10 years ago
today I miss you we're like who the [ __ ]
are you talking to
and then this is the the new version of
that it's just like
it's just like oh I lost some celebrity
I've never met oh Michael Jackson died
I'm so sad [ __ ] you right just keep it
to yourself play a podcast it is
interesting like when like Prince died
like people can't cope and they they
won't go to work for the day yeah it
wasn't even come out with new music it
was done
yeah and so it's like I see it I just
want to mock it so I just always say
something shitty about the guys and then
most people like it and everyone then
like five percent of people are like
fine but I'm mad so you don't run
anything by a team before you say shame
but in in the immediate wake of the Kobe
thing yeah like you did go pretty quiet
like for a moment there dude they yeah I
mean I guess they were using my wall on
on Twitter to like docs my friends and
managers and [ __ ] so like they were like
on like that tweet they'd be like hey
here's his manager's address here's her
phone number go [ __ ] her up So
eventually like oh Jesus you guys are
out of control man yeah but yeah you're
classy people like your fans classy
[ __ ] people
and then uh that that all kind of like
blue
what was what was the bigger uh
catastrophe in your life the Kobe thing
or the drug art oh good question well
that one was worse because my friend
wasn't like he was like he wasn't
talking to me for a while yeah so that
did bother me and his wife was just
exposing dorks yeah and this one just
yeah then burnt's wife still doesn't
talk to yourself yeah Brad is uh Brad
and his wife are [ __ ] he's he's
president but his wife is not it's not a
fan I just said her flowers I'll be like
hey lady I'm sorry I'll stay out of your
way yeah first of all that was the
greatest podcast in the history of
podcasting all right we took Molly and
just [ __ ] had a [ __ ] week
I gave him free Molly dude some of the
finest [ __ ] you can find in New York and
I gave it to him no questions asked wait
wait what was it no questions asked for
sure
we had a [ __ ] blast oh it was fun
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah I do